okay well first of all let me just let
me just clarify what happened I came in
asking what does the red pill movement
mean okay that's literally what I asked
yeah like what do we think that it means
what does it mean because I grew up in
the 90s and I watched The Matrix when it
came out back in the 90s so not to date
myself but I'm dating myself on purpose
and when I remember what I saw from that
movie was Neo was given a red pill and a
blue pill and it was either you go back
to this virtual reality that has been
created for you or you take this other
pill that's going to take you into
reality and it's gonna suck
but take this pill instead and that's
what he does I don't remember which one
he takes it doesn't matter that's not
the point so then I asked her okay but
can you clarify because that seems
pretty self-explanatory taking a pill
that's going to be explaining or opening
up broadening out your mind about what
you're not used to or what you're not
comfortable accepting you've grown up
accepting a certain reality so then the
red pill is about open broadening up
your mind right and then what we then
started talking about was how the red
pill movement has turned into a
misogynist view like man against women
views instead of just like the unspoken
truth about life it's kind of like about
relationships and men and women you know
so that's all we were saying we were
just kind of clarifying there was never
any accusations that occurred well I I I
think the red pill guys take it a little
bit offensive because uh red pill is
supposed to be just a rule set I guess
you could say or something to kind uh
it's it's not supposed to be like uh an
ideology is what Rolo would say the guy
that mostly created he would say it's uh
what What's the word it starts with a P
plaxology yes so um so that's why he
might have felt some type of way when
you said that because uh it's not
supposed to be a movement in that way
it's not supposed to be an ideology you
know that's what we were clarifying with
each other yeah but go ahead Pearl I'm
sorry well I think it's just a lot of
people like call it misogyny when it's
not
um and so yeah that's so let's let's
define misogyny one before we start
everything the hatred of women okay
but okay were you all saying like women
the red pill is like rightfully so
misogynist or were you saying like
um people are labeling that wrongfully
my question was what is the red pill and
why has it turned into a misogynistic
ideal that was my question
I never made any accusations like when I
sat down literally I was just asking a
question
Earl or Austin one of y'all take over
well you said why has it turned into a
misogynist ideal so you think it's
massages
from what I'm aware of and from what
I've seen so far
Clips yeah
can I have an example
um just putting the fat comment the
other day that was inappropriate I don't
know why we made that comment or how we
thought that was okay which comment
um if you're over this amount of weight
no no man's ever gonna love you how is
that massaging what's a realistic
comment that that would be fattest maybe
are you talking about me what was that I
don't know
I didn't say no man's ever gonna love
you
I said I said no one's rude either way I
said no one looks good over 300 pounds
and that's a personal opinion uh yeah
but it's rooted in data like if you look
at if you look at how is a personal
opinion rooted in data because okay
we're talking about General opinions on
the world and the way that the World
Views you
um so if you look at dating app data fat
girls get less swipes bro okay okay but
that's your personal experience that's
the data's experience but okay but the
data but this is apparently data the app
what app Bumble hinge
but nothing out that's generalized I'll
list apps if you don't know and so and
I'll give you I'll give you I'll give
you the context of the conversation like
a lot of times as women like we don't
live in reality and I don't really
understand why like in general in
society thin people get more attention
then people tend to be better looking
I'm not the skinniest girl around but I
can I can say that girls maybe on a
website Society real quick I can also
say having all friends who have the
almost they're beautiful have the best
bodies you know or fit when we go out I
talked about this all the time usually I
would be like because all of them are
really like usually most of my friends
are Hispanic I had to talk to myself and
be like dang maybe it's like because I'm
blasting they're Hispanic you know like
maybe that's why they get chosen but
really it's because like you said if you
come if you're a peer more fit that's
just kind of what guys want personally I
don't go for the
I go for a guy who looks more fit and
like you know health-wise and that's all
personal opinion baby I'm just saying in
Dallas
when we go out to the club and stuff
guys aren't going for me like they're
going for my friend who's more fit like
you know more but I'm just that's just
with men I also now want to also get my
personal experience why are you shaming
men for their standards because this is
the thing this is like a common shame
I'm not crazy
that's an issue with men that's what you
said
because you're saying that that's an
issue with men that is shaming with
shaming language okay and so you're
basically when men say this is my
standard and then you say oh well it's
an issue with men and if you just shame
someone for making a comment of like oh
if you're a fat girl not gonna get
swipes isn't that shaming no it's not
shaming it's based on it's based on data
it's based on what men tend to like data
and so and so and so and the other thing
that we took out of context in the
conversation
I'm not shaming fat people but would you
like to be fat yourself no I mean I take
care of myself would you like to yes or
no would you like to be fat yes
you're asking you do yeah I'll be fat
yes or no but nobody wants you would
like to be fat yes you would like to no
yeah or you wouldn't if she's happy so
that's why I'm happy all she's saying is
one heart attack away from death oh
she's saying
EMT thanks though all she's saying is on
a balance of probabilities men would
rather go with the more fit woman than
the bigger woman okay
I need to speak you know what fit means
no everyone's definition
we need to wait our turns that's what I
was gonna say first of all I was invited
onto this podcast as a guest to share my
opinion let me share my my experience
with my opinions on something okay yes
initially Okay so I lived in Egypt I
lived in Egypt for four years all right
in the middle eastern culture women that
are bigger okay are actually desired
over there all right so we are right now
talking about our Western experience of
beauty standards that's where we hit yes
we are currently here but we are now
also generalizing the whole world about
saying that oh only thin women get
attention that's not true across the
world in a general sense excuse me I'm
not done so as well okay nothing's true
across the world this is not a fair
debate yeah all right so in my
experience in my experience when I was
living over there the men actually
desire a woman that is bigger because
that means that they're being fed
they're being taken care of that is a
woman that is of the household that
knows to take care of her family but it
sounds like she got a man already but
this is the thing when you you're
looking for the exception and not the
rule and this is this is what women
always do whenever we don't like an
uncomfortable truth about the world we
say well in this one remote part of the
world there's an exception rather than
the rule okay but in most countries
across the board people prefer thinner
women
in in your experience in the western
Society
right now you're generalized so so
actually no that's not necessarily true
I I grew up like traveling to different
countries I've lived in Germany I've
been to India I live in England right
now so I've actually I'm pretty cultured
actually I grew up with nannies from
across the world I grew up with Russian
Nami South African nannies Brazilian
nannies uh it was the same
so yeah so as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible